des cavaliers des cochers un roi une
reine sombre et son inquiétant
conseiller le château de chambor s'est
transformé l'espace de quelques jours en
décor de cinéma du cinéma fantastique
brésilien oui vous avez bien entendu
brésilien ils sont près d'une centaine à
avoir traversé l'Atlantique pour tourner
les scènes du premier épisode de la
téénovela cordel encantado qui sera
diffusée sur la chaîne brésilienne
téléglobaux entre avril et octobre
chambor a déjà accueilli des équipes de
tournage par le passé notamment le
célébrissim podane de Jacques réy en
1970 mais cette fois-ci c'est un choc
des cultures que nous explique le
producteur exécutif de la série pour la
France il vienent avec beaucoup de
matériel avec une manière de travailler
qui est un peu différente de la nôtre
quelques particularités dans
l'organisation des équipes et dans
l'organisation tout court qui fait que
pour nous c'est pas évident à gérer
c'estàdire qu'on on a l'habitude
d'accueillir des tournages des
production
étrangère celle-ci est assez
particulière mais ça se passe très bien
il nous manque peut-être un peu de
soleil une expérience originale voire
exotique pour l'équipe française de la
série mais qui n'intimide pas vraiment
la centaine de figurants recruter pour
l'occasion même dans des conditions
météorologiques difficiles certains
prennent leur rôle très à cœur notre
travail c'est de bah de de de de d'être
présent sur les scènes de les faire
plusieurs fois jusqu'à tant qu'elles
soit bonnes donc elles peuvent être
bonne tout de suite mais elles peuvent
être Bonn en fin de journée donc il faut
un certain temps pour les faire il faut
être patient surtout parce que ça
demande beaucoup d'attente et euh puis
parfois comme aujourd'hui il fait très
froid donc on essaie de se réchauffer
comme on peut mais bon faut garder le
moral quoi voilà pour d'autres il s'agit
simplement de vivre un moment agréable
ouis c'est une sacrée expérience c'est
marrant c'est c'est c'est marrant de de
voir chambor comme ça avec les décors et
tout ça c'est c'est la première fois que
je fais ça et c'est c'est agréable c'est
agréable nul doute que les fans de la
série auront l'envie de voir en vrai le
château de chambor le domaine national
devra alors se préparer à une nette
augmentation de sa clientèle
sud-américaine